elle est restée fidèle à poissy la ville
qui l'a vu naître et à son maire
vendredi 29 octobre c'est à la maison de
faire de poissy que catherine lara a
choisi de se voir remettre les insignes
de commandeur de l'ordre national du
mérite ça me rappelle ma tendre enfance
où j'ai connu l'époque nous on avait la
croire nous donner la croix d'honneur
quand on avait bien travaillé donc
c'est quelque part un peu cet enfant là
qui au fond de moi ça me fait plaisir
c'est toujours très un honneur d'être
reconnu par les siens c'est l'ancien
ministre bernard cazeneuve proche de la
rockeuse de diamants qui lui a remis la
médaille qu'elle démarrait ton ami
véritable virtuose tout cela à peupler
une partie de ma jeunesse donc
je suis venu lui dire à quel point elle
était une grande artiste
à quel point elle avait marqué une
génération
il ya quelques mois on l'aimait premier
prix de violon du conservatoire de
versailles premier prix de musique de
chambre du conservatoire de paris
catherine lara pourtant choisi le rock
et la variété plutôt qu'une carrière de
musicienne classique mais c'est sans
doute à ses talents de compositrice
qu'elle doit ses plus grands succès
comme nuit magique où les romantiques
c'est une virtuose de notre beau pays ce
soir c'est un honneur un privilège de
pouvoir honorer une des plus belle femme
de france que notre pays peut avoir
catherine lara c'est le sait la
chanteuse catherine valras et c'est la
violoniste mais catherine lara c'est la
belle personne une belle personne qui
s'est engagé courageusement dont la
cause des femmes et qui fut l'une des
premières à oser faire son coming out
répondant avec humour à michel denisot
qui lui demandait ce qu'elle regardait
en premier chez un homme sa femme